kevin à 16 ans il est arrivé au centre
début août un séjour de quatre mois et
demi pour reprendre pied
ça fait mais à présent le centre comme
alternative à la prison
kevin était en rupture avec la société
[Musique]
comme lui sont six dans ce centre pour
réapprendre les règles du vivre ensemble
[Musique]
pour son travail avec autour de ces
jeunes huit éducateurs pour les
accompagner au quotidien et leur
redonner des codes ou mouiller la
chemise ensemble et c'est en étant avec
eux le faire avec
être avec penser avec et c'est en
partageant des moments parfois
difficiles des bons moments qui va
s'instaurer vraiment une confiance
c'est à partir de là on va vraiment
pouvoir l'extraire de ce passé
judiciaire pour pouvoir aller de l'avant
c'est une association qui gère le centre
la mission principale est de créer une
rupture dans le parcours du jeune tout
en l'accompagnant vers son projet de
sortie cette séquence là tellement
particulière qu'elle va marquer le jeune
dans les souvenirs qu'il va construire
avec ses éducateurs dans une forme
d'identification
notre vocation ça n'est pas de rester
par contre c'est vraiment de pouvoir
semer ses repères redonner du sens kevin
partira en stage dans une semaine dans
une ferme pédagogique
puis il effectuera son stage en milieu
professionnel jusqu'à mi-décembre au
moment de sa sortie